[Music]
right fam
i read this
it resonated with me okay not with me
personally but you can just picture
where you can put yourself in issues
kind of yeah you can pick your ways out
immediately okay right so
i said yo what's good guys
castillo tea
got this dm yeah
all right someone said yo what's good
guys
i hope you're doing well
i've got a question
i had a dream about cheating on my
girlfriend the other night yeah i got
caught in the dream and i felt terrible
yeah i woke up feeling lucky as [ __ ] to
have her and i'd never want to let her
go
but
recently i've been missing my ex
i've been missing my ex wait wait for it
she was toxic and so bad
she used to make me feel suicidal
wow
am i a bad person for missing her
um am i a bad person for missing her
because after i'm done missing her i
hate myself all right sorry am i a bad
person for missing her because after i'm
done missing her i hate myself for it
any advice on what i can do
i was suicidal fam
i love my girlfriend
just the other day i had a dream about
cheating her and i woke up shaking in
fear i woke up in fear i can't lose her
i can't lose her but in the back of my
mind i've been missing my toxic ex
missing the [ __ ] out of her she had me
suicidal she had me suicidal
what
fam
that's sort sick
the definition of toxic that's toxic
what
what what love is in that fam they pro
my when i read it my immediate thought
was
on some amber
hurting
also johnny depp albert yeah yeah johnny
just couldn't leave yeah he caught he
loves her couldn't let her go and i bet
they used to [ __ ] they used to after she
used to rock his jaw they used to bang
and she used to cry and apologize
before she sat on the bed yeah before
she shot on the bed and ruined his life
she used to suck him off oh
it reminds me of when the one i said
sun along the lines of i love my girl
but my ex sucks me that sucks me off the
bench
just the way i like it
those words i can never hear that he
loves his girl because his toxic ex it
stays on his mind this is what they do
[ __ ] they get their claws in you yeah
and you can't escape it it's hard the
venom is in you now yeah literally
you can't you need part ways he's
it sounds like he's
he's um
he's almost like a traumatized you and
he associates love with drama of course
of course of course he associates
arguments with love
and he's in his perfect relationship
it's healthy and feels good
but he needs that drama in his life he's
boring
yeah yeah yeah he's in love but he's
bored yeah
basically he's in love he's [ __ ]
bored so what was it i might he also
fall thinking about her back yeah
i might i might say he didn't even say
am i the assistant i said am i a bad
person for missing her
[ __ ] because when i was over i wanted to
kill myself [ __ ] and that that that gave
him life yeah the adrenaline just ah
every time her phone every time my phone
rang and i saw her name my heart would
beat i don't know what the [ __ ] she's
gonna say
i hated that life but it's all i know it
was invigorating it was invigorating
[ __ ] am i a bad person for thinking
about her
i mean
no
no it doesn't sound like your fault no
it's not because it's clearly not
voluntary yeah like no you're not a bad
person for thinking about her like the
only you'll be a bad person if you acted
on it oh of course you're currently not
acting on you're only thinking about
certain things and stuff about the fact
that you had a dream
the fact that
the situations in your past previous
relationship were that toxic that in
your current healthy relationship you're
having dreams about cheating on your
misses and that's waking you up shaken
to the core yeah yeah which is in turn
giving excitement to then think about
your ex
is a sign that you need to step away
yeah it's a violence you need to step
away from everything and focus on you
yeah yeah that's all you can do right
now take your current girlfriend out the
situation yeah you've got demons yeah
yeah you've got demons yeah bro see
someone see a few people
because you need to step away from every
situation
rebuild your life before you step back
into society it sounds like you weren't
ready for this relationship that you're
in exactly in the first place yeah
because you've got scars
you you haven't had closure in god now
god knows how long and it's starting to
penetrate into your coverage yeah yeah
that's nice try to brush it all under
the rug and it's rearing his ugly head
it's not you want it back you're waking
up in sweats yeah he's moving like an
addict yeah yeah he
is like a heroin addict
he's moving like a [ __ ] quackhead
that's not okay he knows how destructive
that is to his life but he needs it
he thinks he needs it he he does need it
he needs rehab he needs something it
sounds like he went cold turkey um
brother
fam brother listen it sounds like
you were balls deep in this heroine life
you oh deed
and you were ready to die yeah
by the grace of god you made it around
the other side and you went i'm never
touching another needle again [ __ ] this
yeah you woke up in hospital
while you're like wrong i'm alive around
my life [ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm never
touching nothing either yeah yeah i'm
never touching another little again you
went cold turkey
and now you're getting those night
sweats yeah yeah literally you're
getting those night sweats shaking he's
dreaming about playing you've got that
withdrawal
you've got that balls deep withdrawal
[ __ ] and you're thinking maybe hero
wasn't so bad maybe if i just have it in
doses yeah maybe smaller doses might
help me change my life yeah i think
the second time around now i know how
bad it can get i think if we mitigate it
yeah i'm well trained now yeah
now and i'm starting to miss the taste
of heroin
because i needs a little bit yeah i need
a little bit because
this paracetamol think i'm on a minute
it's not touching the surface yeah i've
been smoking weed and it's not doing
anything
i need needles yeah
it needs to be my blood
this wheating injects it dead it's
boring my man said this
this is his profile thing
i need it in my veins [ __ ]
this vanilla thing it's not working
working for me this is ibuprofen i don't
it's nothing it's not doing anything i
need it here yeah yeah i need a main
line [ __ ]
yeah i need it mainline
well what you should have done is you
should have woken up in that hospital
bed take your ass to rehab and they
would have taught you to reprogram your
mind yeah reprogram your heart because
so then you don't associate
any joy with heroin whatsoever you
realize how bad it was for you
and that's it
that's what you need to do so you need
to step away i'm not saying dump your
girlfriend yeah but you need to step the
[ __ ] back
away from your ex your girlfriend your
cheating dreams
and focus on yourself and your health i
think
if you are very honest with yourself the
best thing to do is be honest with her
100
tell her she must know you've had a had
a traumatic um past relationship just be
open and honest with her babes i've been
missing the heroine i'm not going to lie
to you
i've been missing this heroine and i
know it's wrong i know it's wrong it's
[ __ ] with me day in day out and you
probably see it on me but i'm trying my
hardest to shake it off but the nights
where i think i can't
and i can't even sleep because i'm just
shaking and shivering and sweating
you know
and it's not my fault and it's
definitely not yours definitely you're
not doing it you're not doing anything
wrong you're just my partner in this
crime and i'm just i just need to
express to you how i'm feeling because
it's just me and you in this
relationship i thought no one else i've
got no one else to speak to
you're my confidant and i need to let
you know how i'm feeling i need to get
this off my chest because i can't sleep
i can i can literally not sleep yeah the
thought of losing you is killing me the
thought of you is killing me but the
thought of not [ __ ] her is making me
suicidal
i need you i need it and needs one more
i need one
just a taste help me just a taste
[ __ ]
yeah bro get out of there get it off
your chest tell your missus will scan on
if she's the real deal she'll understand
if she's the real deal she'll get it you
need to reinforce the fact it's got
nothing to do with her you say babes i'm
not gonna lie to you i'm gonna speak to
someone about this a professional yeah
because it's not it's not going well i
just need to let you know what where i'm
at mentally where am i so i'm not trying
to be distant with you i just need to
focus on what's going on here yeah so i
can be the best version of myself for
you 100 because i'm not going anywhere i
don't plan on going anywhere yeah i want
this this is perfect i need this it's
healthy for me i need this yeah it's
different and i like it i like it but
sometimes when my back's against the
wall
when i'm cornered yeah oh my god then
idle sundays yeah that unblocked buttons
looking
juicy it's flashing yeah it's pulsating
yeah it's a strobe thing
i'm just hypnotized by it [ __ ] that's
hilarious so yeah bro got it speak to a
professional you think it's because
we're laughing you think it's jokes
we're [ __ ] not joking speak to
someone because this isn't healthy
a man says she turned me suicidal and i
loved it oh no that's dark that's very
dark yeah that's very very dark yeah
speak to a professional bite mig and uh
get yourself out of that hole and never
look at that heroin
[Music]
again you